tenete duro sono fa vj oggi siamo sul
nuovo video con ragazzi il gioco in
questione affected che avevo fatto anche
un mesetto fa soltanto che avevo fatto
solo il primo livello adesso facciamo il
secondo perché minchiate giuro non
vedevo proprio l'ora e quindi ragazzine
che possa lasciarvi al video
sto cazzo di cavo ecco che bello come al
solito ci sono ragazzi non vedevo l'ora
di tornare in sta roba cioè proprio
proprio bello meglio della mia scuola
comunque l'ultima volta avevo fatto the
manor quindi il primo questa volta
faccio di hospital che mi sembra dice
ecco perfetto si passò un pos entrai o
entro qui è la mia mamma rifarà letto
credo si ecco bello concreti
i normali ascensori anno le canzoni
quelle da ascensori che quelle
tranquille
invece no invece questa sentito il ritmo
record e ostica per ragazzi siamo
arrivati mi stavo così divertendo quale
canzone era meglio prima ecco
bene non si può ritornare tipo in
ascensore canto qualcosa non lo so era
più divertente prima cos'è mastrolindo
nei comodi caminati un ragazzo la
madonna
voi dovete capire che io sì posti li amo
cioè bellissimo permesso le scale di qua
perfetto è un po buio e non vorrei dire
ok bene se mai è ovvio che vado di
dentro giuro mi sembra una presa per il
culo giocare star ove però bene non
sarei io io semmai mi trovassi in un
posto del genere piuttosto mi stendo a
terra e e muoio perché non è possibile
sono dottor house devo trovare la sala
operatoria perfetto avete un design per
le serie che porca [ __ ] manco mia nonna
c'è un ospedale in teoria dovrebbe
tranquillizzare i pazienti però qua non
tranquillizza un cazzo bella fratè vista
race io posso entrare nelle porte con la
testa è questa io io amo questo gioco è
una roba salvi una donna manco outlast
così brutto pestone autras colo colo
slip che bello salve giorno cioè si è
chiusa mi sa che s'è chiusa scontate una
ginocchiata pazzesca grazie è bello da
tanto non ci volevo entrare reflue a
like you qua dentro 1 mil avere neanche
il culo però ok e nero va un ritmo
seriamente la che cos'è o cazzo si vabbè
ma cosa fanno gli esperimenti non fanno
chi è che al mona che sbatte la porta e
così pietro rogato ok ok ragazzi
no no non lo sa che sei tu ti sei
dimenticato nonno ciak sedia io non lo
so perché il 6 avvenuta senza di lui chi
cazzo ha lanciato stanno seriamente ma
stai giocando tipo a bowling con le
sedie a rotelle non lo so non si gioca a
bowling con le sedia a rotelle intel ha
mai detto la mamma perfetto è di qua i
ragazzi sto continuano andare avanti
senza capire un cazzo di dove sto
andando da [ __ ]
esploso muro che sposò ragazzi mi sono
quasi beccato una scheggia di moore in
faccia prime io non pago la
ristrutturazione qui è tanto dovete
anche vernicia non solo le porte si
chiudono e si aprono come quella stronza
lì davanti anche i muri adesso devono
tartassare le balle della saras
caramagna e la suite corale giorno
comunque non so sapere se è accorto se
io ma denti ma anche una scarpa però va
bè ragazzi è un figo c'è ancora st porta
che si apre e si chiude da sola qui si
dorme così ci si arrangia giorno da
tamedia
se mi cadi in testa ti uccido la mamma
lo sapevo ci avrei scommesso tua madre e
tuo ego è portato vestito in tintoria
per favore io sono straconvinto ragazzi
che la porta di merda l'isola sta
ridendo
madara
dalla rai lei è un paziente di che
guarda che c'è degli amici che ti
presento amico mio hai per caso voglia
di dirmi dove sei andava bene non posso
entrare qua dentro minchia troppo voi
ragazzi quasi quasi centro però era roba
allucinati vabbè ma non possono fare
certe cose però così io riesco a ragazzi
riesco con il mio potere che riesco a
vedere attraverso le porte vedo un morto
grazie comunque fantastico si può per
permesso grazie è chiusa stasta non ci
sono porte lo cacciava dodi 40
ciò posto dubbi non si è aperta questa
perfetto meglio così ma c'era un morto
qui dentro non voglio andarci e allora e
allora mi spiegate dove è andato quel
tizio che non ancora le sedie bastasse
serie a secco yo yo ciò il dubbio che
stasera mi venga addosso proprio secondo
me mi carica di brutto premesso sedia
non fare cazzate sedia è brava brava
così brava perfetto le sedie sono mie
amiche per le porte no però sono finito
nei cessi posso scaricarmi nel cesso
così esco di qua porterà da qualche
parte lo sciacquone di temi di serio io
non ho capi non so dov'è finito quel
tizio di prima ma se mi devo pagare
addosso a me non so dove andare
una volta nella vita voglio conoscere
chi fa i design dei dei giochi oro
voglio stringermi la mano voglio capire
un attimo che che problemi hai promesso
di non rompere le palle
hai promesso ecco bravo ma perché si la
promessa è una promessa seno tp a calci
in culo stare attento più che ai mostri
alle porte alle sedie non ha senso sta
roba
ok questa stanza è molto più allegra
delle altre vedo è la tua ultima chance
per tornare indietro è ma c'è la sedia
che vi vuole mangiare non possa fa male
cos'è che fa male se stampi le manate
sul muro è ovvia che fa ma grazie a caso
è la madonna la divina commedia non ho
mai letto così neanche a scuola
ascoltati o questo questo telo leggi tu
perché non mi stai prendendo due ti tiro
una testata ragazzi diciamo no alla
discriminazione delle porte perché non è
possibile
papà affanculo [ __ ] anno entrato
nella foto non è una cosa proprio
fantastica messi certo tra l'altro qua e
anche bloccato adesso ad andare per
forza di qua devo andare perfetto ragala
possiamo finire in questo caso di
ospedale che non ne posso più per favore
grazie no seriamente non ce la posso più
fare basta di qua si può uscire c'è un
ascensore di merda da qualche parte vi
prego no io io io io sotto i morti non
ci passo ve lo scordate ragazzi mi
dispiace abbiamo il culo veloce veloce
veloce veloce veloce veloce che belli
che siete veloce veloce di qua di
qualità se ce lo fa dove siamo è brutto
[ __ ] di una barella e morta però è
per questo succede ad aggredire fa
vigenti
hai visto perché loro hanno tentato di
aggredirmi sono morti grazie molto genti
è la madonna tutta sua gentilezza si può
tornare indietro devo sottopormi io a
qualche esperimento o cose del genere
mi sa di sì ragazzi siamo mi siedo posso
sedermi quasi questi ragazzi pre gara
regala ragazzi ragazze dentro il
comodino
fai qualcosa che è bello che si scotta
ceo io no no no no regalo ce la faccio
io sto facendo un po tolgo l'occhio alla
porta
una donna
è finito così si macchia e cosa orribile
appena giocando ragazzi è stata
l'esperienza più bella del